This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1933, several nation-states, including the US, got together in Montevideo, Uruguay, to define what it means to be a state. The treaty they came up with includes 16 articles, each of which lays out different rights and duties of statehood. That's producer Julia DeWitt. But the most famous article is number one, which sets out the four basic criteria of statehood. That's producer Julia DeWitt. But the most famous article is number one, which sets out the four basic criteria of statehood.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1933年，包括美国在内的几个民族国家在乌拉圭蒙得维的亚聚在一起，定义了什么是国家。他们达成的条约包含16条条款，每一条都规定了国家地位的不同权利和义务。那是制片人朱莉娅·德威特。但最著名的条款是第一条，它规定了国家地位的四个基本标准。
Basically, what it takes to be a country. The state as a person of international law should possess the following qualifications, a defined territory, a permanent population, a government, and capacity to enter into relations with other states. I think a good flag is crucial too, but that's just me. Well, even if you toss in a flag, the criteria for becoming a state seem to some people
基本上，这就是成为一个国家所需要的条件。作为国际法主体，国家应具备以下资格：确定的领土、永久的人口、政府，以及与其他国家建立关系的能力。我认为一面好的旗帜也很关键，但这只是我的个人看法。好吧，即使你加上一面旗帜，成为国家的标准在有些人看来
surprisingly simple. So simple, that a lot of people thought, hey, I could do that. And so, for a lot of people that just triggered, I suppose, an idea that that meant that they could just call their house an independent country. That's John Ryan. These are countries that might even just be somebody's backyard or it could be an area that they are claiming for one reason or another to be an independent country. John Ryan is the co-author of the guidebook, Micronesians, the Lonely Planet Guide to Homemade Nations. And yeah, this is the same Lonely Planet that publishes tourist guides to places like Mexico and France.
出奇地简单。简单到很多人想，嘿，我也可以做到。所以，对很多人来说，这只是触发了一个想法，即这意味着他们可以把自己的房子称为一个独立的国家。那是约翰·瑞安。这些国家可能只是某人的后院，也可能是他们出于某种原因声称是独立国家的地区。约翰·瑞安是《微型国家：孤独星球自制国家指南》的合著者。是的，这就是出版墨西哥和法国等旅游指南的那个《孤独星球》。
John says most of these micronations are just kind of for fun. They aren't expecting anyone to take them seriously, and they don't usually meet all for criteria laid out by the Montevideo Convention. Places like Molassia. Which is in Nevada, just in one guy's house. Such a lovely guy, President Kevin Bow and he runs this great little micro nation. He gets about in military regalia and reflective sunglasses. He looks totally like a central American dictator from the 70s or 80s.
约翰说，大多数这些微型国家只是为了好玩。他们并不指望任何人认真对待他们，而且他们通常不符合蒙得维的亚公约规定的所有四个标准。像摩洛西亚这样的地方。它位于内华达州，就在一个人的房子里。凯文·鲍总统是个可爱的人，他经营着这个很棒的小微型国家。他穿着军装，戴着反光墨镜四处走动。他看起来完全像70年代或80年代的中美洲独裁者。
Malacias' currency is pegged to the price of Pillsbury cookie dough. So they'll go up and down in value as cookie dough does. A few years ago, Malacias' President Bow started the micro-national Olympics where micro-nations compete against each other in events like checkers and the boomerang throw. Malassia is fairly easy to dismiss as just one dude's crazy projects. But then, there are places like Sea Land. Probably the world's most interesting and fascinating machination is Sea Land. And Sea Land cannot be dismissed so easily.
摩洛西亚的货币与皮尔斯伯里饼干面团的价格挂钩。所以它们的价值会随着饼干面团的价格而波动。几年前，摩洛西亚的鲍总统发起了微型国家奥运会，微型国家在跳棋和回旋镖投掷等项目中相互竞争。摩洛西亚很容易被视为一个人的疯狂项目。但随后，还有像西兰公国这样的地方。西兰公国可能是世界上最有趣、最迷人的微型国家。西兰公国不能轻易被忽视。
The state as a person of international law should possess the following qualifications, a defined territory. If you search for the principality of sea land on Google Maps, it comes up as a little red dot off the east coast of England. Zoom in for some photographs of the place and you'll see a metal platform sitting atop two concrete pillars. A stilted structure
作为国际法主体，国家应具备以下资格：确定的领土。如果你在谷歌地图上搜索西兰公国，它会显示为英格兰东海岸外的一个小红点。放大看一些照片，你会看到一个金属平台坐落在两个混凝土柱上。一个高跷结构
in the ocean surrounded on all sides by the North Sea. The platform is about the size of a football field. So pretty small territory as countries go. So how did this platform and the sea become a micro nation? Well, you could say it all started with rock and roll. Good morning, everyone. Tony Blackburn here. Would you feel your little under the weather this morning? We've got about an eight-fourth gale out there,
在海洋中，四周被北海环绕。平台大约有一个足球场那么大。所以作为国家来说，领土相当小。那么这个平台和海洋是如何成为一个微型国家的呢？好吧，你可以说这一切始于摇滚乐。大家早上好。我是托尼·布莱克本。今天早上你感觉有点不舒服吗？外面有大约八级大风，
so I'm strapped in the seat this morning. In the 1960s, the British government wasn't giving out enough licenses to accommodate all the music that the kids were suddenly demanding. So a bunch of DJs decided to take matters into their own hands. They set up pirate radio stations on ships and on abandoned British forts in the North Sea to broadcast rock music back to England. This is number one and they count down this week. From the Spencer Davis group, it's called Keep On Running. Keep on running. Keep on hiding.
所以我今天早上系好了安全带。在20世纪60年代，英国政府发放的许可证不足以容纳孩子们突然要求的所有音乐。所以一群DJ决定自己动手。他们在北海的船只和废弃的英国堡垒上建立了海盗电台，向英格兰广播摇滚乐。这是第一名，他们本周倒计时。来自斯宾塞·戴维斯组合，歌名叫《继续奔跑》。继续奔跑。继续躲藏。
One five day come on a p-girl. One two, make you wonder. Well, C-land is so physically as an old wartime fortress built in 1943. It was built in the North Sea to defend the United Kingdom against German aircraft that were following the river Thames up to London and bombing London. That's Michael Bates, Prince of Sea Land. Back in 1967, Michael's dad Roy was one of the DJs trying to turn these old abandoned forts in the sea into radio stations. But don't be fooled. Roy wasn't just a rock and roll love and hippie. He was a free market capitalist. Here he is being interviewed about his pirate radio ventures.
好吧，西兰公国实际上是一个建于1943年的旧战时堡垒。它建在北海，旨在保卫联合王国，抵御跟随泰晤士河进入伦敦并轰炸伦敦的德国飞机。那是西兰公国的迈克尔·贝茨亲王。早在1967年，迈克尔的父亲罗伊就是试图将这些废弃的海上旧堡垒变成广播电台的DJ之一。但别被骗了。罗伊不仅仅是一个热爱摇滚乐的嬉皮士。他是一个自由市场资本家。这是他接受关于他的海盗电台创业采访时的情景。
More and more business people and more and more businesses are becoming educated to use commercial radio. And this is as it should be. I would like to see radio used for every form of advertising, but there is use in every other media now. In any case, Bates and the other DJs kept getting slapped with big fines from the British government. So Michael Zadroy changed course. He scrapped the idea of a pirate radio station and decided to go for something even bigger. My man always liked the challenge.
越来越多的商人和企业开始受教育使用商业广播。这本该如此。我希望看到广播被用于各种形式的广告，但现在其他媒体都在使用它。无论如何，贝茨和其他DJ不断受到英国政府的巨额罚款。所以迈克尔的父亲罗伊改变了方针。他放弃了海盗电台的想法，决定追求更大的目标。我父亲总是喜欢挑战。
I was talking to his lawyer friend one day. My father said, what if I declared independence? Roy Bates wanted to start his own country. And Lionel, his friend said, well, no, you can't do that. And I thought, well, why can't I do it? So my father went ahead and did it. Roy thought the fort was uniquely suited for independence because of its location. It was six miles off the coast of England, and at the time, England's territorial waters
有一天我和他的律师朋友聊天。我父亲说，如果我宣布独立会怎样？罗伊·贝茨想建立自己的国家。他的朋友莱昂内尔说，好吧，不，你不能那样做。我想，好吧，为什么我不能做呢？所以我父亲继续做了。罗伊认为该堡垒因其地理位置而非常适合独立。它位于英格兰海岸外六英里处，当时英国的领海
only reached three miles offshore. Three miles because that is how far a cannonball can fly and break through a foot of oak. So it's sort of a dated law. It's been since changed to 12 miles. You know, we got better cannons now. But back then, with this 3 mile rule, Roy considered the fort, which again was just a platform perched on two concrete towers out in the ocean. Roy considered this claimable territory.
仅延伸到离岸三英里。三英里是因为那是炮弹能飞出并击穿一英尺橡木的距离。所以这是一种过时的法律。它后来被改为12英里。你知道，我们现在有更好的大炮了。但在当时，有了这个3英里规则，罗伊认为这个堡垒，也就是海洋中矗立在两个混凝土塔上的平台，是可宣称的领土。
He didn't buy the platform, he didn't ask permission, just gathered up his family, and moved them there. The government might call this squatting, but for the bait's family, this was nation building. And so, on a blustery day in 1967, a nation was built. Celand has a national anthem. And they have a flag. It's actually a pretty good flag. It follows all the principles of good design. It's simple, has three flag. It follows all the principles of good design It's simple as three colors red, white and black Well the red is for Roy the black is for his days in part radio and the white line down the middle of it Is the path of purity that he travels today. I think he was slightly telling a cheek on that one the country's motto is
他没有买下这个平台，也没有征求许可，只是召集了他的家人，搬到了那里。政府可能会称之为非法占用，但对贝茨一家来说，这是国家建设。于是，在1967年一个狂风大作的日子里，一个国家诞生了。西兰公国有国歌。他们还有一面旗帜。这实际上是一面相当不错的旗帜。它遵循了良好设计的所有原则。它很简单，有三种颜色：红色、白色和黑色。红色代表罗伊，黑色代表他从事海盗电台的日子，中间的白线是他今天所走的纯洁之路。我想他在这一点上有点开玩笑，这个国家的座右铭是
From the sea freedom on that one. The country's motto is, from the sea, freedom. The state as a person of international law should possess the following qualifications, a defined territory, a permanent population. The population of Cieland consisted for many years of four people, Roy Bates, founder, plus his wife Joan, his daughter Penelope, and his son, Michael. Roy named his son Michael Prince, and his daughter, Princess. He didn't call himself King now. I think he thought I was a bit over the top.
从海洋中获得自由。这个国家的座右铭是：从海洋中获得自由。作为国际法主体，国家应具备以下资格：确定的领土、永久的人口。西兰公国的人口多年来由四个人组成：创始人罗伊·贝茨，加上他的妻子琼、女儿佩内洛普和儿子迈克尔。罗伊称他的儿子迈克尔为亲王，女儿为公主。他没有称自己为国王。我想他认为那有点过分了。
Before Michael was a prince, he was just a kid from England. He was 14 and in boarding school when his dad moved them all out to Celand. Michael didn't think it would last for long. I envisaged six months, a lot of it would have been an adventure for six months, and all of the same. That would be the end of it. Michael and his dad ended up living on Sea Land for about 25 years. For the most part, it was just Michael and his dad, mom, and sister out on the platform.
在迈克尔成为亲王之前，他只是一个来自英格兰的孩子。他14岁，正在寄宿学校读书，当时他父亲把他们全家搬到了西兰公国。迈克尔没想到它会持续很久。我设想了六个月，六个月的冒险，然后一切照旧。那将是它的终点。迈克尔和他的父亲最终在西兰公国生活了大约25年。在大多数情况下，平台上只有迈克尔、他的父亲、母亲和妹妹。
They built a house, set up a water gathering system, and filled some of the rooms in the towers with canned food. Nowadays, the rooms are fully furnished. There's a non-denominational chapel, generators for power, there's even a gym where you can work out. But back when they first started, the place was pretty bare bones. Sometimes when the weather got bad, and their resupply boat didn't show up they'd get a little hungry on those days They would eat fish that they caught and biscuits from a box when Michael would get sick of being on a metal platform out in the middle of the ocean He would hitch a ride on a boat back to the mainland to find kids his own age I mean I came back up he straight out into a night club or something like that. That was a good time They say let's do when they hit port, I suppose.
他们盖了一所房子，建立了一个集水系统，并在塔楼的一些房间里装满了罐装食品。如今，房间设施齐全。有一个非宗派的小教堂，有发电的发电机，甚至还有一个可以锻炼的健身房。但当他们刚开始时，这个地方非常简陋。有时天气变坏，他们的补给船没有出现，他们会有点饿。在那些日子里，他们会吃捕到的鱼和盒子里的饼干。当迈克尔厌倦了待在海洋中间的金属平台上时，他会搭船回到大陆寻找和他同龄的孩子。我的意思是，我回到岸上，直接去夜总会之类的。那是一段美好的时光。我想他们到达港口时就是这样做的。
I hope there wasn't quite as bad as that. And sometimes he would even bring friends back to sealant. I just muggle women out there, and my tap wasn't too keen, but I just muggle women out there with that tele. Of course. I tried to lead a normal life, even though I was in an odd place. The state as a person of international law should possess the following qualifications,
我希望情况没有那么糟糕。有时他甚至会带朋友回西兰公国。我只是把人带到那里，我父亲不太热衷，但我还是带了人去。当然。我试图过正常的生活，尽管我身处一个奇怪的地方。作为国际法主体，国家应具备以下资格：
a defined territory, a permanent population, a government. Sealand has various government posts apart from the monarchy. Their tax lawyer is their minister of foreign affairs, and the caretaker that stays out there when they're gone is head of Homeland Security. He's the one that issues visas and stamps your passport if you visit. Their legal code is pretty simple.
确定的领土、永久的人口、政府。西兰公国除了君主制外，还有各种政府职位。他们的税务律师是外交部长，当他们离开时留在那里看守的人是国土安全部部长。他负责签发签证并在你访问时盖章。他们的法律准则非常简单。
They basically have all the same laws as England. Well, almost all the same laws. Unlike England, C-LAND allows guns, Prince Michael loves guns. But they never really had to use them, except once. There aren't a lot of ways to make money on Sea Land, which meant the family was always trying to come up with money-making schemes. And sometimes these schemes got a little weird. In 1978, Roy, Michael's dad, started talking to some businessmen from Germany, Austria, and Belgium. They wanted to build a leisure island around
他们基本上拥有与英格兰相同的所有法律。好吧，几乎所有相同的法律。与英格兰不同，西兰公国允许持有枪支，迈克尔亲王喜欢枪。但他们从来没有真正使用过它们，除了有一次。在西兰公国赚钱的方法不多，这意味着这家人总是试图想出赚钱的计划。有时这些计划变得有点奇怪。1978年，迈克尔的父亲罗伊开始与来自德国、奥地利和比利时的商人交谈。他们想在西兰公国周围建造一个休闲岛，并放一个赌场。有一天，罗伊和他的妻子去奥地利与一些资助者谈论这笔交易。在西兰公国，当时25岁的迈克尔正在守卫堡垒，这时一架直升机出现了，一群人降落到平台上。第一个下来的人我认得。迈克尔认识直升机上下来的这些人中的一些，是他父亲曾经共事过的人。其中一个是西兰公国政府成员，外交部长。一个叫亚历山大·阿肯巴赫的人。
Celand and put a casino on it. And one day, Roy and his wife went to Austria to talk with some funders about this deal. Back at Celand, Michael, who was 25 at the time, was figuratively holding down the literal fort when a helicopter showed up and a group of men lowered themselves to the platform. The first man down a recognize. Michael knew some of these guys coming out of the helicopter as men his dad had worked with. One of them was part of Cielan's government, its minister of foreign affairs. A guy by the name of Alexander Aachenbach.
但据迈克尔说，阿肯巴赫试图将迈克尔一家排除在赌场交易之外。他据称正在策划政变。所以他对迈克尔说，嘿，我刚和你父亲见过面，他把西兰公国转让给我了。现在它是我的了。迈克尔心里想，没门。我不相信你。
But according to Michael, Aachenbach was trying to shut Michael's family out of the casino deal. He was allegedly staging a coup. And so he says to Michael, Hey, I just met with your father, and he signed C-land over to me. It's mine now. And Michael in his head is like, no way. I don't believe you.
我坐下来想，也许你最好回到直升机上，把我父亲带出来。迈克尔走进屋子给大家拿饮料，就在这时，迈克尔说阿肯巴赫和他的打手猛地关上大门并设置了路障，把迈克尔困在了自己的家里。我被困在里面直到被放出来。四天后，迈克尔的俘虏把他送上了一艘去荷兰的船。流亡在荷兰，迈克尔联系了他的父亲，父亲证实他当然没有
And I sit down and I think perhaps you'd better go back in the helicopter and bring my father out. Michael goes into the house to get everyone some drinks, and as he's doing this, Michael says Aachenbach and his goons slammed the front door and barricaded it, trapping Michael in his own home. And I was in the full rising tool until I was let out. After four long days, Michael's captors put him on a boat to Holland. Exiled in Holland, Michael gets in touch with his dad, who confirmed that of course he hadn't
把西兰公国转让给阿肯巴赫。他们制定了一个夺回国家的计划。他们打电话给一个有直升机公司的朋友。我们解释了情况。他们说，好吧，我会带你们去那里。在起飞前，他们拆掉了直升机的门，并在滑橇上系了绳子，这样当他们到达西兰公国时，他们可以像海军海豹突击队那样滑下绳子，突袭平台。他们在半夜起飞。
signed Celand over to Aachenbach. And they made a plan to take their country back. They call up a friend who has a helicopter company. We explain the situation. They say, okay, I'll take you out there. Before they take off, they remove the doors from the helicopter and tie ropes to the runner so that when they get to Zeland, they can slide down the ropes, Navy Seal style, and storm the platform. They take off in the middle of the night.
如果我们在黑暗中乘这架没有门的直升机飞越北海，他们滑下绳子降落在西兰公国的平台上。我们只是滑下绳子，我是第一个下去的。当我到达甲板时，我可以看到所有的德国人跑出大楼。每个人都在用德语大喊大叫，到处乱跑。迈克尔爬上了大楼的屋顶。顺便说一句，带着一把锯短的猎枪，我忘了提了。如果你没听清，他说他有一把锯短的猎枪。然后我从屋顶跳了下来，大约12英尺高。他从屋顶跳了下来，据迈克尔说，枪意外走火了。
If we fly out over the North Sea with no doors in this helicopter in the dark, they slid down the ropes onto the platform of Celia. We just slid down ropes and I was the first one down. As I hit the deck, I could see all the Germans running out the building. Everyone was shouting in German and running around. Michael climbed up onto the roof of the building. With a sauna shotgun by the way, I forgot to mention that. In case you didn't catch that, he said he had a sawdoth shotgun. And then I jumped off the roof as of that 12-foot-hine. He jumped off the roof and, according to Michael, the gun accidentally went off.
砰，它走火了。砰，它走火了。每次它上下晃动。那一枪足以吓得入侵者投降。罗伊和迈克尔放走了所有非西兰公国公民。但外交部长亚历山大·阿肯巴赫并没有那么容易脱身。阿肯巴赫背叛了王室。他们以叛国罪起诉他并对他进行了审判。好吧，我父亲是法官，所以可能有点偏见。但他们把阿肯巴赫关押起来，直到一位德国大使真的来到
Boom, it went off. Boom, it went off. Every time it went up and down. That one shot was enough to scare the invaders into surrendering. Roy and Michael let all the non-citizens of Cilan go. But the minister of foreign affairs, Alexander Aachenbach, did not get off so easily. Aachenbach had betrayed the crown. They charged him with treason and brought him to trial. Well my father was a person I didn't judge, so it kind of might have been slightly biased. But they held Ackentbach prisoner until a German ambassador actually came out to
西兰公国谈判释放他。最终他们放了他，所有的敌对行动也就此结束。当德国政府派大使出来谈判释放其公民时，迈克尔说，这让他们与西兰公国建立了正式关系，这满足了成为国家的第四个也是最后一个标准。作为国际法主体，国家应具备以下资格：确定的领土、永久的人口、政府，以及与其他国家建立关系的能力。他们勾选了所有的方框。你几乎没有什么可以说服他们放弃
Sea Land to negotiate for his release. Eventually they let him go and with that all hostilities were ended. When the German government sent their ambassador out to negotiate the release of one of their citizens, this, says Michael, has them entering into formal relations with C.L.A.D. which fulfills the fourth and final criterion for being a state. The state as a person of international law should possess the following qualifications, a defined territory, a permanent population, a government, and capacity to enter into relations with other states. They've ticked all of the boxes. There's very little that you can say to dissuade them from
合法性，真的。我们是谁，能说它不是一个国家？那是再次提到约翰·瑞安，他写了《微型国家指南》。虽然他可能承认西兰公国符合成为真正国家的标准，但大多数专家并不这么认为。哦，绝对不是，它不是一个国家，不。那是尤拉·维德马。尤拉是牛津大学的研究员，也是国际法专家。他深入思考过是什么让一个国家成为国家。
legitimacy, really. Who are we to say that it's not a country? That's John Ryan again, who wrote the Lonely Planet Guide to Migrenations. While he might concede that Cieland fulfills the criteria for being a real state, most experts do not. Oh, definitely no, it is not a state, no. That is Yura Vidmar. Yura is a fellow at Oxford and an expert in international law. He's thought a lot about what makes a state the state.
西兰公国只是一个废弃的平台。它不是一个真正适合居住的地方，通过将那次事件解释为与其他国家的关系。我的意思是，他们试图将自己的案例纳入公约，但我的意思是，这是一个被推得太远的笑话。这并不意味着蒙得维的亚公约毫无价值。它只是不完整。尤拉说，真正重要的是承认。归根结底，这是政治性的。如果说，世界上有190个国家承认西兰公国是一个独立国家，我想毫无疑问它就是一个独立国家。但是
C.L.A.L.A.N.T. is just an abandoned platform. It is not really a viable place to live and by explaining that incident as relations with another state. I mean, they are trying to fit their case within the convention, but I mean, it's the joke that was taken actually quite far. Which doesn't mean the Montevideo Convention is worthless. It's just not complete. What really matters, Yeri says, is recognition. The end of the day, it is political. If, say, 190 states of this world recognized sealant has been an independent state, I think there would be no doubt that it was an independent state. But
这当然永远不会发生。有很多地方符合蒙得维的亚标准，无论对错，美国并不认为它们是国家。例如，巴勒斯坦得到了其他135个国家的承认，但没有得到美国的承认。还有台湾。台湾符合所有标准。它有永久人口、政府、确定的领土，并且能够与其他国家建立外交关系。台湾目前得到22个国家的承认，主要是图瓦卢和布基纳法索等小国。但中国仍然认为台湾是中国的一个省，因为我们不想惹恼中国，所以我们也不承认
this would of course never happen. There are a lot of places that meet the Montevideo criteria that rightly or wrongly, the US does not consider nations. Palestine, for example, is recognized by 135 other countries, but not by the US. And then there's Taiwan. Taiwan meets all the criteria. It has a permanent population, a government, a defined territory, and they are able to enter into diplomatic relations with other countries. Taiwan is currently recognized by 22 countries, mostly small countries like Tuvalu and Burkina Faso. But China still considers Taiwan to be a Chinese province, and because we don't want to piss off China, we also don't recognize
台湾是一个国家。尽管美国政府确实向台湾派遣大使，但我们只是在派遣他们时让他们辞职，然后在他们被调往另一个职位时恢复他们的职务。所以如果中国对此有任何意见，我们可以说大使，什么大使？所以也许国家地位更多是一个程度问题。有些国家得到120个合法国家的承认，而另一些国家只得到5或10个国家的承认。截至目前，没有人正式承认西兰公国是一个国家，甚至连图瓦卢或布基纳法索也没有。
Taiwan as a state. Although the US government does send ambassadors to Taiwan, we just technically make the ambassadors resign when we send them and then we reinstate them when they're transferred to another post. So if China says anything about it, we can be like ambassador, what ambassador? So maybe statehoods more a matter of degrees. Some states are recognized by 120 legitimate countries, whereas others are only recognized by 5 or 10 countries. As of this moment, no one formally recognizes C-land as a state, not even Tuvalu or Burkina Faso.
至于西兰公国的人口，随着创始人罗伊·贝茨变老，他发现住在大陆更容易。他于2012年在英格兰埃塞克斯去世。迈克尔结婚了，他的新妻子坎普·布拉默不喜欢平台上的生活，所以他也搬到了英格兰大陆。这些天，只有国土安全部部长住在平台上。但迈克尔亲王喜欢它在那里，以防他想搬回去。西兰公国可能永远不会拥有真正的主权，但与此同时，英格兰从未正式收回它。可能是因为这样做会比
As for the population of C-land, as Roy Bates, the founder, got older, he found it easier to live on the mainland. He died in Essex and England in 2012. Michael got married and his new wife, Camp Blamer, didn't like life out on the platform, so he moved to mainland England too. These days, it's just the head of Homeland Security that lives out on the platform. But Prince Michael likes the idea that it's there if he ever wants to move back. Sealand will likely never have true sovereignty, but at the same time, England has never formally reclaimed it. Probably because doing so would be harder
让它继续保持现状更难。所以即使他们海上那个被风吹过的平台可能不算什么，但它是他们的。他们的旗帜依然飘扬，至少目前如此。《99%隐形》本周由朱莉娅·德威特和凯蒂·曼格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在奥克兰首屈一指的建筑和室内设计公司Arxine的办公室制作，位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。
than just letting it keep being what it is. So even though their little wind swept platform on the sea might not be much, it is theirs. And their flag still flies, at least for now. 99% invisible was produced this week by Julia DeWitt and Katie Mangle with Sam Green Span, Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW, San Francisco, and produce out of the offices of Arxine. Oakland's premiere, architecture, and interiors firm, and beautiful beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter和Instagram上。我们有一个Spotify播放列表，各种各样的东西。但你了解99PI所有内容的大本营是99PI.org。Radio toio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter and Instagram. We have a Spotify playlist, all kinds of stuff. But your home base for all things 99PI is at 99PI.org. Radio toio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook上找到并关注本节目。我们也在Twitter和Instagram上。我们有Spotify播放列表，还有各种各样的内容。但99PI所有相关内容的大本营是99PI.org。Radio toio。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。